- But he's so kinda addicted
to work at this point,
I don't know when they're
gonna sell the house.
I understand that he gets a
lot of fulfillment out of it,
but at the same time, he's
so stressed out all the time.
- Hey, can I sniff your butt?
- Yeah.
- I think I wanna be your friend.
- Cool.
- Hey, hey, hey, that's my pole!
Okay, I guess it's your pole now.
Hey!
Hey, Henry!
(brown-haired man groans repeatedly)
This is how I sweat!
(sounds of exertion)
I don't even know why I'm doing it!
The pipe is mine!
Hey, if your stomach is upset,
you should eat some of this grass.
It'll help.
Hey, can I sniff your butt?
- [Brown-Haired Man] No.
- [Blond Man] What are you,
some kind of tough guy?
- I don't know what your name is, but
I think you may be my best friend.
- Hey, hey, hey, hey!